I think it's crazy it's 2023 we still
make women feel bad for being
promiscuous slots are the best huh
why would you make them feel bad
you know what the best time to be a
promiscuous woman was was Native
American time Inca Aztec Mayan causation
sacrifice virgins to the gods they throw
them at a volcano holy [__] I'd be the
biggest [__] on the reservation
I mean it could save your life Chief
walks up how ma'am crops are dying we
gotta sacrifice a virgin you a virgin no
huge [__] huge [__] you are way off
baby way off all right I give the best
Arrowhead on this side of the Wigwam
okay
you don't know what you're dealing with
all right I put the hoe and Navajo out
here okay
yeah you know my tribe name spread eagle
that's me yeah
yeah I gotta tell you I think I like
that system better rewarding the fun
gals get rid of the boring ones you know
you know there was some Chief up on the
volcano going you should have [__] me
whoa hey all right [__] look at that
[Applause]